hi this is pressed I worker and today
I'm going to explain why 2% milk is
really 34 percent fat we'll start by
taking a look at the nutrition label for
milk
the name 2% milk refers to a measure of
milk fat by weight this is calculated by
taking the total weight of fat and
dividing it by the total weight of food
so we know that 2% milk is 2 percent
milk fat by weight but that's not the
relevant measure for dieters most people
are curious how much of this fat does it
contribute to my daily total by that
measure the 5 grams of fat are actually
8 percent fat by daily value a final
measure is that most dieters care about
calories and they want to know what
percentage of the calories are coming
from fat what happens when we take a
look at this measure 2% milk has 42
calories from fat and it has 125
calories surprisingly we find out that
2% milk is actually 34% fat by calories
now you may wonder why 2% milk goes by
the name of 2 percent milk fat by weight
rather than the 8 percent fat by daily
values or the 34 percent of fat by
calories and just saying this out loud
makes you realize that the number which
was picked was the lowest one it sounds
a lot better to call it 2% milk than to
call it 34 percent fat this is a game
that other food products use as well
hebrew national beef franks advertises
that it's 97% fat-free and that's
because it's true that only that it's
only 3% fat by weight when you look at
the percentage of fat by calories it's
actually 25% and this somewhat makes
sense that you wouldn't necessarily
think that beef franks
are low fat food
other food items also claim that their
very high percentage of fat-free and
again they're true because it's fat-free
by weight but not fat-free as a
percentage of calories so there's a game
theory lesson here which is that foods
that advertise health claims are
signaling that they are not necessarily
enough that they could survive without
these claims
so the counterpoint is that if you want
to look for foods which are actually
fat-free you're going to want to look
for foods which don't advertise at all
and that means you should probably stick
to fruits and vegetables thanks for
watching and please subscribe you can
follow me on my blog bind your decisions
or on Twitter at pressure Walker and get
my ebooks at Amazon